Chuck you don't have to look too deep
into the news to find all kinds of ways
that we're all going to die oh
yes it's why I like the news you know
when I when I get depressed I just turn
it on and you know sit back and and
bathe in apocalyptic you knowy Grandeur
yes it's wonderful
you know there's the asteroid there's a
killer virus there's AI yep and the list
goes on and on and people like stay up
nights thinking about ways we're all
going to die and the one that is treated
the most lightly however is one that I
think should be given a little more
serious attention okay and that's that's
the zombie
apocalypse okay I'm going to ride with
you for a second I'mma ride with you for
a second okay yeah I
mean all right okay you don't think I
got this you don't I got this L hey
here's the deal I've doubted you in the
past and it has worked out so I'm gonna
give you a little more leeway right now
but you know I gotta tell you uh this
twig is very
thin I don't know if it can support all
this
weight okay so the zombie apocalypse is
all right the way it's typically shown
in a movie right is there's some virus
that affects a person right and they
bite you and then you're affected by
that virus but that virus manifest by
killing you right and then you come back
to life right yeah and using then the
virus is basically you're a host for the
virus in your in your state of being
Undead Undead correct correct by the way
there's a key and Peele skit about the Z
zombie apocalypse did you ever see it no
okay so they're in the Suburban
neighborhood
and these zombies are coming down the
street and ke and Peele they own homes
on this street and they the the zombie
comes towards them then
pauses stops and then just keeps
walking I won't bite them these are
racist zombies
that's a that's a good bit that's a good
bit that was hilarious pretty funny so
all all the white people in the
neighborhood were like running for the
hills and they're out in their backyard
playing pingpong in a barbecue it was
just what what would it be if zombies
were
racist so that's the idea and so they're
Undead and you got to buy into that
premise and then you have the whole
movie right all right okay so one thing
that The Walking Dead did so well in
their
series is to show for you
that sometimes what we have to fear most
is
ourselves and not the zombies okay now
that I can go with if if you knew
zombies were like everywhere taking
everything
out then who's in
charge who has access to the goods and
services and foods and things you need
to survive Society right right societ so
all of a sudden Society becomes a wild
west in the face of a zombie apocalypse
okay so for me I think a little
differently well I I think more sharply
about the zombie apocalypse to me the
zombie apocalypse is the person who
drives the truck the people who drive
the trucks that bring the
food from the Farms to the grosser or
from the canning facility to the
distribution facility they're taken
out zombies don't drive trucks right
okay the person who controls the water
treatment plant that then sends clean
water into your pipes is taken
out the person who uh delivers gasoline
to the gas station or fills up or or the
the power station
they're taken
out so a zombie apocalypse is not
fundamentally
different from a
pandemic right we saw some of this at
the beginning of coid the supply chains
were broken right because people stayed
off the roads and other people got sick
so you're not you're not driving a truck
that day you're not you're not running
the grocery store that day and then what
happen s if the grocery store is open
what do you do well you go in and you
buy 800 rolls of toilet paper that's
what you do exactly I mean clearly
that's the only thing to
do how big is your ass that you need
exactly you
know so yeah I would have bought food
I'd find other ways to wipe my ass is my
how I would think about that you know
yeah I mean I think it was oh no it was
spring it was spring yeah you know I was
gonna say they we've been using leaves
forever human beings have been using
leaves since the beginning of time so
you know toilet paper is not really the
number one priority okay as far as I
would have seen it okay hey Star Talk
fans you know there's been a lot of talk
about comedians making up stories and
then passing them off as real life
experiences and that's why I'm inviting
you to get tickets to the taping of my
comedy special on November 17th and 18th
and fact check the hell out of me the
special is titled Chuck Nice just smart
enough and hopefully I'm smart enough
not to lie but there's only one way to
find out and that's go to Chuck KNC
comic.com and get tickets to Chuck ni
just smart enough at the midnight
theater in Manhattan on November 17th
and 18th two shows each night and
remember facts don't lie but I just
might so I'm so in a zombie apocalypse
forget the zombies what's happening is
society begins to shut down right and we
are so
dependent on even the littlest things in
society all right if the electric
company goes out and you got to put gas
in your car the pumps run on electricity
yeah okay if you have an electric car
when you're not recharging unless you
have solar panels okay now supposed to
solar panels break you call solar panel
fix it man no they're taken out by the
virus yeah yeah and so
systematically civilization as we know
it
unravels Y and let me tell you this when
I'm driving in a car and I see a deer
crossing the road or I see an eagle
flying above or I see a squirrel or
chipmunk I say to
myself in the apocalypse they're just
fine yeah nothing changes nothing
changes for them they know where to get
food they know how to mate they know
where to live and get shelter they know
what to do from one season to the next
and they might hibernate they don't need
anybody and so here I am here we are as
humans saying well we're smart and we're
this
you know by the way Chu who said that
humans are the smartest creatures ever I
think it was probably a human a humans
I'm pretty sure pretty sure it wasn't
aliens saying oh on the on the grand
scheme of no we declared that right and
so now in a darwinian sense your your
ability to survive the survival of the
fittest didn't mean you had the biggest
muscles it meant you were capable of
thriving in an environment you were best
fit for that environment right and so we
created a civilization I don't know how
to gut a deer right I don't know how to
chase a turkey right I don't know how to
you know that is why you have got to get
yourself a friend who has a
bunker
now any friend with a bunker knows how
to do all of those things I live in the
wrong part of the country for people
that have bunkers with with AR-15 I'm
sure there's there's plenty of Bunker
people who would be very honored to be
friends with Neil degrass Tyson you know
it's just like we're pulling for the
zombie apocalypse CA Neil's coming over
guys you know just gotta make sure you
don't get bit on the way did I tell you
I ordered one thing in a survival
catalog there was some funl looking
knife that I wanted and one thing it's a
survival catalog mind you okay and ever
since then I've been on the mailing list
right for guns for for uh uh uh tactical
gear
for so that's how they roll you you can
buy a box of food just Add Water keep
you going for three years yeah exactly
yeah yeah I bought a um a uh
self-defense uh protection I'll call it
it's basically a weapon I don't want to
say what kind but uh you would think
that I was Chuck Norris not Chuck Nice
not Chuck Nice
the the mail that I get I'm just like
clearly they do not know who they are
sending this mail to you
know so there's there's a cat called LA
Police Gear where you know you get it's
like okay this now I know what everybody
else is reading when I'm reading you
know the I need that now LA Police Gear
is a catalog that I want to have I'm
ordering everything in it so that when I
get stopped by the cops and they're just
like on the ground I'm like you on the
ground
were the last words Chuck Nice ever
said get on the ground you get on the
ground no no they'll just see the
catalog on the seat next to you oh go
ahead that that could be it too you
never know that'd be it so so the point
is that ask yourself how much of your
survival depends
on the efforts of others to maintain the
civilization that you're plugged into
yeah and and like I said we saw bits and
pieces of it for Co and Co virus was 3%
fatality right the morbidity there's a
these mean slightly different things
right but the total the fraction of
people who contracted Co who died right
that was in the low single digits and so
if that had been higher 20% 50% oh my
goodness and it start it was working its
way through civilization then
civilization shuts down and you are
basically on your own
that's exactly what happens in a zombie
apocalypse so I think we need to devote
more attention to the creativity of the
writers and the producers who do these
zombie stories just to see how the
people are reacting in the face of lost
Services they even know in the zombie
shows you don't use a gun to kill the
zombie because guns use what bullets and
somebody's got to make the bullets and
if that person doesn't show up at the
factory you ain't going to have bullets
I got to tell you the uh the my favorite
zombie um series of all time is The Last
of Us on HBO and it's because of
everything you just said it doesn't
really focus on zombies it focuses on
our relationship with one another in the
breakdown of society and it just shows
how different groups of people how they
coess and become their own subciety and
they think about their their survival in
different ways and and what they'll do
and what their priorities are so I'm
just saying um you know zombies are we
we we're scared of zombies but as you've
clearly indicated there Chuck at the end
of the day maybe it is
we who we should fear not the zombies
themselves I'm going with
both I'm already scared of
us if zombies show up I'm gonna be
scared of them too
by the way there's some you know people
make up their own zombie rules which is
fine as long as it's consistent there
was one uh storyline where the zombies
could not move backwards they can only
move forwards oh which meant they cannot
open a door that opens inward
right yeah that's a dumb rule you
know that's all I got to do is get put
your life on it yeah all I got to do is
get behind you
now right and then don't turn around and
go backwards so that was one rule and
then a movie I didn't see uh uh uh Z
what's that movie World War Z it's a
good zombie movie there some fast moving
zombie zombiie should not be able to
move that fast that ain't right and
unrelenting there it's just crazy like
that ain't right the zombes should not
be able to run I'm sorry and run faster
than anybody that's what made yeah
that's not how they ain't got no
ligaments in their bones and no the most
I'll give them is in the Thriller video
they can
dance I'm down with that by the way the
only zombies I'm not afraid of I'm like
those guys they're they're too
entertaining just one more number before
you bite my brains just one more guys
please one more one more one more so
anyway that's all I wanted to talk tell
you about ask yourself how dependent are
you on civilization itself and then
consider the zombie apocalypse and
you're the first to go well there you go
there's something good to think about
during this
season perfect season to think about
zombies and the breakdown of society as
a whole I
like all right that's all I got for you
CH okay all right there's been another
star talk explainer on the zombie
apocalypse Neil degrass Tyson your
personal astrophysicist keep looking
[Music]
up